where do you land on religion stuff
these days i'm an atheist atheist yeah
you're you're like can okay i just want
to ask you because i hear people call
you a christian rapper
and i listen to your music and obviously
there's like like stuff in there that's
like
godly right like blinds but it's not
like
i don't look at you that way i just look
at you as like a rapper who happens to
be a christian
as opposed to being like a because you
know when i grew up man christian rap
was corny as [ __ ] yeah yeah and um
i feel like lecrae was like the first
guy to come along to be like oh no he's
just dope he can rap yeah but he also
you know is obviously like how do you do
you consider yourself like quote unquote
christian rapper or is that something
that you embrace well for
it's an interesting combo because for
years i've just tried to like
just be like yo can i just be a rapper
and be a part of the community because i
always felt like in some way in hip-hop
to be called
something before your title
like a female rapper a gay whatever a
christian a mother so you know gender
orientation or religion anything those
that precede a title it always feels
like it marginalizes like right away
people already have yeah so it's like oh
she's that's a female rapper right you
know it's all those things so
i tried to just be like man i
i feel like i'm just a part of hip-hop
but i am a christian so i would never
deny being a christian right just be
like
that title it's a weird it's a weird
conversation because people be like oh
yeah we'll play you on sunday then you
know on the radio you're like
i took a meeting one time uh
one of my albums the first neverland it
was like doing really well on the charts
i took a meeting at this is 50. and 50
cent was there and so i walked by him i
was like yo what's up man he was like
lifting weights and uh
he was like you know didn't give me no
time he was like yeah yeah what up and
then his man was like yo he got the
number one album on itunes right now and
then he was like oh word coming to my
office right so i ended up hanging out
with 50 for like two hours
random i'm like
i looked at my manager i was like yo i'm
gonna go on the off yeah and i went in
he just started asking me questions
cause you know at that time like he's
just a smart dude he wants to learn so
he's like you have a number one album
like what's going on
starts asking me all these questions i
start telling about this i'm like yo
when i first started like
you know
ten years plus years ago
i had some very
explicitly christian bars i was juiced
up about my relationship with jesus ah
you know so i think that's where that um
initial thing comes from you know what
i'm saying and a lot of my core fans
uh share those same ideas right so
you get that but over the years just my
sound my view the way i approach things
has evolved and
so
anyways when i was talking with him he
was like yeah bro people are going to
try to if you continue
basically like if people continue to see
you that way and just not a part of
hip-hop they're going to try to
marginalize you to the
gospel hour on sunday or something you
know i said i was like oh man
that was never my intention but
at the end of the day i've just let go
of trying to control that
narrative to a degree because it's like
you're just gonna do you and like let
people feel how they feel that's it man
at the end of the day you can't really
control it and it's also it's like when
you tell people hey man i i don't really
call myself that then that becomes the
the headline of the interview
and it just it's a circle you know i'm
saying so i'm like whatever y'all want
to call is the music dope